أشعل حروباً عالمية،
فظن الكثير أنها نهاية العالم،
وبعد طفولة مريرة بالفقر والحرمان،
أصبح رساماً فاشلاً، ثم تطوع في الجيش
وانهزمت بلاده، فتسلق على سلم الحقد والكراهية
لينتقم لخسارة بلاده، ورقص على رؤوس الثعابين،
فتملك أكبر حزب في ألمانيا،
فعل باليهود مالم يفعله أحد من قبله ولا من بعده.
فبمحرقة جماعية، وإبادة تاريخية،
نسج هتلر شهرته العالمية،
وهنا سنتوقف قليلاً عند تعليقاتكم متابعينا الأعزاء،
ففي الجزء الثاني من حياة هتلر، تلقينا وابلاً من الاعتراضات،
فحواها لماذا نتحدث عن المجازر التي فعلها هتلر بحق اليهود
رجالاً ونساءًا وأطفالاً وكأنه مجرم سفاح،
فاتهمنا البعض بأننا وقفنا مع اليهود ضد هتلر
((وعن حقوق الإنسان)) وما إلى ذلك،
والإجابة ستكون خلال دقائق هذا الفيديو.
مرحباً بكم متابعي قناة شاهد لتعرف في الجزء الثالث
من قصة الزعيم النازي أدولف هتلر.
كيف كانت نهايته؟
وهل مات منتحرا أم قتله أعداؤه؟
أم أنه هرب ونجى بنفسه؟
قبل الإجابة على هذه التساؤلات
لا تنسوا الإعجاب بالفيديو والاشتراك بالقناة وتفعيل الجرس
كنا قد عرضنا في الأجزاء السابقة من حياة هتلر،
ماذا فعل باليهود؟ فظهرت بعض التعليقات
وهنا سنجيب عليها من ناحيتين..
الأولى: ألمانية..
قبل  صعود هتلر للسلطة،
كان اليهود مجرد أقلية مقارنة ببقية الطوائف في ألمانيا،
حيث كان اليهود يمثلون ٢% من الألمان،
وعندما تسلم السلطة كان عدد اليهود لا يتجاوز ٥٠٠ ألف نسمة،
وبقية الشعب عددهم ٦٠ مليون.
على الرغم من هذه النسبة القليلة جداً لليهود،
فإنهم كانوا قد سيطروا على 50% من الإعلام
وشغلوا 70% من مناصب القضاة،
وفرضوا وجودهم فى الصحافة والسينما والمسرح، وحتى الأدب.
لقد تم الإفراط فى تقديمهم وإبرازهم. و خلال هذه السيطرة
تسبب اليهود بالكثير من الانهيارات الاقتصادية
التى حدثت للبنوك الألمانية في تلك الفترة،
وهذا الكلام ليس كلام النازيين الألمان وإنما كلام اليهود أنفسهم،
فقد خسر الآباء الألمان آنذاك فرصهم واستثماراتهم وأعمالهم..
إما استولى عليها اليهود، أو كانوا السبب لضياعها.
الناحية الثانية.. عربية..
عربياً، فإن محرقة الهولوكوست لا تقل بشاعة
عن المجازر التي ارتكبها اليهود بحق الفلسطينيين،
فمنذ بداية الاحتلال الصهيوني إلى اليوم
قتل اليهود أكثر من ٣ مليون فلسطيني،
معظمهم من النساء والأطفال والشيوخ (مؤلم جداً).
ومن أجل ألا ينسوا اليهود الهولوكوست،
فقد اعتاد  على قرع الأجراس وإطلاق صافرات الإنذار
لكي لا ينسى أطفالهم ما صنع بهم هيتلر.
في المقابل.. كيف سينسى العرب ما صنعه اليهود بهم؟
فاليوم قد أصبحت رسالة هتلر واضحة
(كان بإمكاني أن أقتل اليهود جميعهم لكن أبقيت على بعض منهم ليعرف العالم لماذا قتلتهم).
وبالعودة إلى هتلر نفسه،
فقد اختلفت التقارير والروايات،
حول طريقة موته،
فمنها ما يقول إنه هرب،
ومنها ما يقول إنه قتل، ومنها ما يقول إنه انتحر..
القول الأول، هو أنه هرب إلى قارة أمريكا الجنوبية،
إلى الأرجنتين تحديداً.. وهناك لم تستطع الاستخبارات الروسية
الوصول إليه، أو أنها وصلت إليه لكنها لم تستطع أن تفعل به شيئاً
لأنها في دولة العصابات، لكن هذا القول غير مرجح.
القول الثاني، أن الجيش الروسي بعد أن أسقط برلين،
استطاعوا الوصول إلى هتلر والقضاء عليه بطريقة أو بأخرى،
لكن في الحقيقة فهذا قول ضعيف أيضاً..
القول الثالث أنه انتحر..
وهنا يتحدث الحارس الشخصي للزعيم النازي هتلر
(روشوس ميش) قائلاً:
(عندما سألنا الزعيم هتلر وقال:
هل سقطت برلين؟ هل خسرنا الحرب؟
فقالوا له إن جيشه لم يستطع كسر حصار الجيش السوفييتي على برلين،
وإن الحرب العالمية الثانية على وشك أن تنتهي بحتمية فوز السوفييت)
وهناك سمع ميش، هتلر يتحدث بهدوء إلى مارتن بورمان
وغيره من المسؤولين في الحزب النازي، كما رأى القائد المتقاعد
أوتو غونشه يصافح هتلر قبل أن يخرج ويغلق الباب على الزعيم النازي وزوجته".
وقال ميش :لقد سبق أن أبلغ هتلر محاميه
بأنه لا يريد أن يُستخدم جسده بشكل سيء علناً،
كما حدث مع موسوليني، وأنه يريد حرق جثته.
وكان الجميع في المخبأ ينتظرون بحذر،
ومع بعض الشجاعة قام ميش بفتح باب غرفة هتلر لينظر إلى الداخل.
وهذا هو القول الأكثر ترجيحاً.. فأدولف هيتلر،
ذهب مع عشيقته إيفا براون إلى مخبأ الفوهرر في برلين،
وهناك أُعلن زواجهما الذي لم يدم لأكثر من ٤٠ ساعة،
بعد قصة حب طويلة.
ويؤكد بعض الحراس أن هتلر انتحر مع حبيته
بحبات سم السيانيد، بعد أن وضعت إيفا هذا السم
في فم أطفال هتلر وهم نائمون، لكي لا ينتقم الجيش الأحمر منه بالتنكيل بأبنائه،
ولم يكن انتحاره بالرصاص كما يشيع البعض
بأنه وضع فوهة المسدس في فمه بعد أن قتل حبيبته،
فالحراس هناك لم يسمعوا أي إطلاق للرصاص،
وبعد أن انتحر هتلر قام حراسه بوضعه وحبيبته في حفرة وتم إحراقهما،
لكن حينها أصابت المكان قذائف مدفعية،
فتطايرت جثة هتلر إلى أشلاء ولم يعرف منها شيء حينها..
لكن تظل كل هذه أقاويل، ولا يوجد دليل قاطع
بأن هتلر مات بهذه الطريقة أو تلك،
فقط توجد بعض الترجيحات لبعض الأقاويل.
بينما يعتبر البعض يوم انتحار هتلر يوماً تاريخياً،
لأنه أسهم بشكل كبير في إنهاء الحرب العالمية الثانية،
إلا أن التقارير تثبت أن هتلر أحد أكثر الشخصيات الأكثر تأثيراً في القرن العشرين،
وإلى هنا نكون قد وصلنا، إلى نهاية الجزء الثالث من قصة الزعيم النازي أدولف هتلر.
فماهو رأيكم متابعينا..؟
هل كان هتلر بطلاً قومياً دافع عن وطنه وأرضه وانتصاراته؟
أم كان ديكتاتوراً وسفاحاً وطاغية؟
وهل مات منتحراً حقاً؟
ننتظر إجاباتكم وتعليقاتكم.. إلى اللقاء